Franklin: Hi, I'm Franklin.
I've lived in a lot of different places.
My family's always on the move.
(mellow music playing)
This was it, our new town.
- Do you want to--?
- (Laughing)
Excuse me.
Making new friends can be hard.
- I’m Franklin Armstrong.
- My name is Charlie Brown.
♪ "Already On My Side" by Ashley Clark ♪
The big soapbox derby race
is coming to town!
The winning team gets a trophy
and free pizza for a whole year!
(Cheering)
What do you think Charlie Brown? Partners?
Charlie: Partners.
♪
Hey, Franklin,
what kind of music do you like?
The godfather of soul, James Brown.
You’re not related, are you?
- I don't believe so.
- (Franklin laughs)
♪ No matter what they say ♪
Franklin: My grandpa always says
you’ve got to want it to get it.
Let’s see what we can really do!
♪
- (Both yelling)
- Franklin: Friendships are not perfect,
but we can get through
the rough spots together.
(Chirping and laughing)
A best friend is someone
you can totally trust...
- (Both laughing)
- ...that always has your back.
(Laughing)
(Yelling)
- (Cheering)
- child: Charlie Brown!
Go, go, go!
Hey, Franklin,
we saved you a seat over here!
Franklin: You know you’ve found your home
when you’re surrounded by good friends.
♪
♪ Time's already on my side ♪